[Applauso]
ci faremo una nuova challenge e flying
con la ruota invece della pausa
challenge ha più pensato perché non
facciamola riavvolgi alle hawaii
noi abbiamo un telecomando non lo è se
succede qualcosa che non si piace
possiamo cliccare il re wilde è tornare
indietro nel tempo dovremo soprattutto
tutte le volte che voglia di ripartire
vi mando da perché tutto richiede come
se non avessi mangiato
quindi se io ad esempio prendere il tè
nero io posso fare così fatto così male
sarà super divertente mi raccomando
lasciato un bel like se volete vedere
altre challenge line pazzo e consigliati
sicure che challenge fare nei commenti
c'è un'altra regola però siccome so già
che litigheremo un sacco perché andremo
sempre indietro riavvolgiamo sempre
tutte sarà un partito svoltiamo il suo
primo polvere due volte questi dobbiamo
stare attenti a utilizzare le due volte
solo quanto ci serve
si fece più di due volte volé c'è anche
un rewind nella ruota quello che
possiamo usare infinito in pieno e lo
stesso sono un sacco di qos cattive come
giusta la slide scambiano sliven sceglie
l'altro pensati dopo che il tesoro etica
e super divertente lasciato un bel mi
piace invece tiri comodi
prendete i papponi che utilizzano lo
vediamo arrivano subito stato svegliato
eraldo in pennarello al morire subito
duro percorso permettere non cose da
mangiare o la capitana vacuum anime
papini e quindi la mia zia messo troppa
chiudersi provante sventato dovrebbe dai
band
vediamo che colore dice milioni canta
ragazzo tira ma che cazzo ne skyrim sarà
anche una brusca lo sanno tutti che ho
fatto cadere un po di cose ma non ho mai
stato fortunato un bellissimo colore
rosa
andiamo a mischiare i vostri primi
ingredienti bello sei stato fortunato un
bellissimo colore dall'inizio ma
potrebbe capitarti qualcosa di brutto
che poi mischiato girano marroncino
grigio i tuoi preferiti ma che beccarini
come rosa chiaro con i diritti io invece
ho tantissima schiumato ne ho messo
tutto a porro non so bianche per info
rischiarla tutta questa sicuro di te
papig vediamo ci sto riuscendo piano
piano anche perché schiuma di kpi non è
come la schiuma da barba normale ma
rimane più rigida vedete perché una
stima apposita per fare tipo le forme un
po difficile da mischiare ma più o meno
si sono il sito dai saggia trasbordo
red bol bando tutto dalla ciotola venga
allora ho detto che presto raggiungerà
zucchero acqua ai rientranti tra i
bancari
ma la vittima basta va bene tutto ma mai
sia ben sigla finale è stato fortunato
ma io abbastanza vediamo tutta di
capitali come sollevarla così si
incorpora o no se l'altra dai vincere
mario già aperti vita capita tutto lo
slam per di noi si aspetta un idea e ha
fatto ho riavuto il tutto quindi ho
usato uno dei miei riavvolgi rimuove
domani fa sapere quindi nuovo
ingrediente per tavoletta bellissima
ecco che allora tu che te credo vada in
giro più veloce
cade impari a scegliere il verde per me
che cosa c'è di vero sono indecisa se
scegliere il rosso ma forse non esce
marrone col rosso matrice un bel colore
rosso quindi forse meglio di no oppure a
tim perde piace quindi dire che forse il
peggiore sarebbe tenuto dalla mini
calare più alleviata da vitale perché
potrà ferme in crisi
ora devi solo decidere se sacrificarti e
lasciare che io metta in verizon mai
ebbene gli sprechi di cui i guai non
poter non è vero tocca a me a questo
strano un ciclico nella schiuma da barba
vabbè metto l'acqua magari sembra sativa
chiamo io adesso di più non è messo
molto a un bersaglio zio di un dato ben
da tavolo puoi scegliere qualsiasi cosa
scegliere toccare confermato però
mischiano berlino
[Musica]
no ho preso ma sono bollino cosa
impensabile verrà presto meglio pensavo
di aver preso una di questa rete è stato
fortunato
ecco che vedrà infatti inventata ok tu
devi mischiare un po è tutto cosa
vorresti che uscisse ne dica no no no no
no fatto quasi ma quante cose stai
rischiando la nostra ammette mi dite
perchè diventerà tipo 1 slime nuvoletta
celeste bello fluff pizzeria ora che le
nuvolette possono essere anche grigie
una più veloce il sereno o che bello mi
piace un sacco nero
riuscirà uno slideshow per bellissimo il
mio ne esci c'è ancora un po di acqua
che non avevo girato bene quindi devo
girare un pochettino meglio speriamo che
continui così bene questa gialle a
guarda che bello il mio con un rosa
delicato con le palline e sai perché è
garbato io
target zia che teniamo di più belle
canzoni io vorrei io vorrei un po di
schiuma
grazie per l'occasione dunque vediamo
vediamo vediamo altre mai visto che hai
messo tutti che c'è marino visto che hai
messo tutti i glitter celesti
magari si potrebbero mettere un po di
frutta al verdi si confondono poiché le
per celesti vedi che non sono stato
tanto cattivo o forse non è d'accordo
neanche berlino che ne pensi di trovare
con questo che ciò sia di milito ancora
io non posso sprecare il mio timore
perché potrebbe potrebbe capitare
qualcosa di peggio quindi devo per forza
accettare
va beh sì ci sta bene un po di colori e
costringendo chiarino li di getto
celeste ghiacciare mettiamo i nostri
ingredienti ecco qua mettiamo
l'ingrediente maledetto cento capitale
perdono migliorano rigetto league e
china penso a proprio guardando
lamenterà verde come sospettato si
vediamo è un bertolino molto chiaro
verde acqua avere un po perde acqua meno
male non è troppo verde
meno male
purtroppo mischia aspetta prima la
rompiamo non è fortuna è perché sono
bravissimo a quello di slide ma non è
vero
mi sembra strano sembra strano anche a
mega in forno anche buon profumo tra
l'altro dicevo sembra strano anche a me
che ancora non è diventato di rigetto
che bello guarda lo slime più bello che
ho mai fatto forse no gatti nominativi
delle cattive telecamere colorante per
te la tua cantiere per rovinare il tour
live band buffa di mettere tutti per ora
senza prime fonti non ti preoccupare
tube dati per poter rovinare così gli
ufo cantone canzone
[Applauso]
ok fatto se gli devo stare molto attento
a quello che cerco dove stanno tutti
aspetta me ne sono dimenticato critici
cosenza
che cosa io penso che diventerà un
bellissimo marroncino elettro preferito
se vuoi puoi fare un rewind ma miei
altri nodi con grandissimo a guardare il
colore bellissimo che era uscito fisico
rimane così una regia per dello spreco
per quei dati a me anch'io colorate
bendato ieri teniamo bene tanto
qualsiasi colore bello ricordando come
la fa aperta lì che hai fatto
[Musica]
vai sicura
[Applauso]
l'acqua infatti sul mese perché ho visto
bravo a verde questo ma tour che si va
benissimo ma il mio turchese
come avevo predetto da diventando
successo ma sta diventando una nuvoletta
profuso celeste sembra un po verde verde
acqua per la famiglia quell'altro
colorante che avevo una buona parte
valute non l'ho mai vista quando era che
bellissima bella flo cosa che invece
vediamo come diventerà il togo ha già il
matera bruttissima cosa che bello per te
che non è stato riavvolgi zaia come si
fa a guardate che bello vi ho già capito
tutto liquidino marrone marrone marrone
e marrone non ho parole
abbiamo che rosa mantenga
ogni tiro colombo mi fido la poetica di
arancione pastello dai di stato
fortunato nel testo non terminato troppo
il pasticcio di ottava arancione busti
mele sono migliorato con questa maggiore
è la ragione allora sono le gerarchie
stato color pesca anche sorprese come
pasta rovinarlo vediamo attiva
non so se scegliere il nuovo a 20 numero
oppure un'idea su come rovinarlo
ma si asciuga la situazione vento
propria che è il cacao
anzi no verde arancione uscirà
sicuramente un marroncino questo mi sono
salvato per ora non puoi più fare
tocca a me
vediamo questo caso davvero abbellire di
hunter bellissimo traguardo vuoi
prenderlo 1 valutato peggio di così
sì ci metto un po di blu
così va via questo verdino acqua ma
diventare blu che perde ecco fatto e
anche metallizzato questo colore vediamo
un po niente se adesso il beatle chiesa
era bellissimo ma c'è il fortunato quali
bari possa scendere comunque 6
vediamo vediamo col color pesca cosa ci
sta bene e ti geekblog alice nesti sai
che non lo so metto questi che sono un
mix tra scuola tra viola e blu ma non
c'è da noi ed era dentro slime io faccio
come voglio io
peggio per te allora metti ligure
diverso è metti sonora ci stanno bene
penso però io dico di free duck hunt è
un bravissimo su raiuno le tue mani
bellissimo e in dio che belli più care
no almeno bellissimo perché c'è questo
colore fantastico con il glitter
mi mancheranno la figlia carrello che
fanno il mio lo slam momi tino avevo
fatto riprendere questa cosa credo tanto
bene
decisivo your eyes quindi sarà ancor più
rischiosa ma il sale 6 perché ora siamo
arrivati all'ultimo turno del fiore wide
quindi devi per forza accettare gennaio
potremo mettere in questo slide no
emesse chi fa più
sono indeciso e trani rosso che forse
diventa marroncino moviola
mi fa male perché mi piace anche io la
mia vita oppure la paletta e violo tutto
il viola
sì ma tanto si sa bene che ti prendi lo
slide viola che volete rovinare che
riprende tutto bellissimo scrive deve
mai mancare mai protetto da challenger
come il karma stein carmen la cattiva
come buono con te quindi questa volta
che ieri tutto indietro
eh sì bari che si impara è risollevata
stimare vediamo qual è il più bello
aveva reso il video è la mia sfida a
cambiare sarà rovinato dalla sua stessa
scelta non ci posso credere veramente
problemi antirottura doveva capitare
vediamo adesso non ho idea di che colore
è un'altra come sta uscendo carino
vediamo vediamo
forse non è male come pensavo io pensavo
che sarebbe diventato marroncino con
questo arancio
invece no è diventato bellissimo
violetto quindi vediamo una volta attivo
come sarà ma per fortuna non è diventato
orribile insomma alla fine siamo stati
abbastanza fortunati in questo challenge
devo lasciare in altri slam e poi
potrete votare per chi vince pronti 32
ma il governo guardate che ben si sa il
colore che la consistenza sono stessi
perché ancora non avete visto al mio le
palline fanno un po di sony craxi anche
la schiuma di peppa pig il colore mi
piace tantissimo perché un viola tipo
lilla sentiamo un po di sony adesso
[Musica]
è davvero bellissimo mi piace tanto devo
questo colore vediamo ora quello
digitale
vediamo se batte di via del colore
presenti scambiato con me sembrava sei
stata brava e fortunata ad avere questi
colori però c'è stato ammette quindi
licata tema the bells hawking esce molto
bene boing perché c'è sia acqua sulla
schiuma da barba
quindi un sacco di rumori sentiamo
adesso le bollicine e un po grossi anche
o cattivo palline come sconfitto la
russa a bollicine non posso smettere
sconfitta che morì a chiazze vediamo un
po questo è il mio viola lilla baby york
il mio celestri stupendo fantastico il
colore mi piace tantissimo di test del
supporto to anche fuoco sono tutti il
credito la difficile scegliere chi min
se per questo anche toni mai
votate quando sono giù se vinco io o se
vince vitale scrivete siri commenti che
aster challenge slide volesse vedere e
ora vi lascio quattro cartellini su cui
cliccare cercate su quella che preferite
e morali indiane ciao